the oranges of the opposite of Lee in
fact is is the chemical weapons you know
a ban of chemical weapons which was in
fact ambitious by the international
community by the States Parties by the
countries for years and especially after
the massive use of chemical weapons
during the first world war there were
several attempts to ban to prohibit the
production of those weapons as the
special values but those attempts
unfortunately failed there was again use
of those weapons in 1980s and finally it
is this decided to negotiate very
comprehensive legal document the
chemical weapons Commission in Geneva in
1980s and the negotiations ended in 1992
and it was opened to signature as it
happens to all treaties and it must the
signatures were completed then vacation
processes it entered into force in 1997
so this is the Chemical Weapons
Convention and in order to you know
oversee and monitor the implementation
of the Convention the country's decided
to establish an organization so this is
the organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons and our task is to
verify to monitor the implementation of
the convention whether the countries are
doing the right thing or wrong thing if
they do rotting we just warn them so you
should not do that but you should do
this and so far the implementation was
very satisfactory to my pleasure
and there are still six countries which
are not yet members we want to get them
on board as soon as possible of course
and this price Nobel Peace Prize we
hoped it will help us in fact to
sensitize those countries and to raise
awareness also in general and we have to
appreciate them there is no reason from
my point of view for not taking such a
decision and
the commission and the organization